Joe Jonas and sophie Turner pull off the
surprise wedding of the year it all went
down right here in this room in the
little white wedding chapel in Las Vegas
and we have details that you won't hear
anywhere else because only week we are
the only show with the man who
officiated over the wedding thank you
very much the surprise Elvis I Do's were
live streamed by the DJ Diplo but only
we have these exclusive photos the
newlyweds with groomsmen Nick and Kevin
and with the Elvis impersonator who
officiated Jessie Garon first of all was
this pre-planned
did when did you know I do about five
minutes for the wedding ceremony he
actually knew somebody was getting
married we didn't know who they had
blocked off the whole chapel from 8:00
to 12:00 so you walk in you see these
people yes what goes through your mind
is a goddess things that cake in the
ocean after exchanging ring pops the
newlyweds kept the party going hitting
their hotel hot tub and check out the
couple's keepsake wedding certificate
signed by the Reverend Elvis himself so
why was this the perfect place well
think about this Elvis got married in
Las Vegas fifty-two years ago on May 1st
and this entire wedding only cost $600
plus a hefty tip for Reverend Elvis
thank so Perry afterwards in there yes I
would fish at sea no but here's the best
part there is a more formal wedding in
the planning for later this year and
that's gonna take place in Paris for
those I Do's sofie's including her Game
of Thrones bestie she's already starting
to think about what she's gonna wear to
your wedding
she's my maid of honor Sophie and Joe
announced their engagement with matching
Instagram post nearly 19 months ago the
23 year old actress shared this advice
on making it work I think the key is to
remember just love and be loved just
hours before tying goodnight Joe his
brothers and the Jay sisters took over
the Billboard Music Awards Priyanka
rockin with the ladies before smooching
husband Nick Joe and Sophie vibing on
his ex Taylor Swift opening with me and
while the video broke Deebo records with
more than 100 million views Taylor's
getting some hate for her performance
The Beehive accused her of copying
Beyonce's Coachella performance the
marching band though pink and a leotard
the hashtag Mayo Chellis started
trending but both have actually done the
drumline thing before Beyonce and 99 and
Taylor in 2009
last night she was definitely award show
tailor getting down and tearing up while
fangirling over Mariah Taylor even
mouthed we love you to the icon award
recipient whose eight-year-old twins
also stole the show from their nervous
mom I would like a do-over but right
well no hate for Drake taking home 12
awards
he's now billboards most decorated
artist ever and a lit up Twitter name
checking this G ot Slayer he shot out to
Arya Stark for putting in that work last
we go now Drake getting some hate
because of the Drake curse any team that
he treats for always seems to knees and
now Game of Thrones fans are worried
that Arya has been cursed by Drake to
die
[Music]
[Applause]